maybe there's nothing else for rajable  to do maybe he just needs those Queens  off urgently in order to maintain the  status quo yeah what do you think of  okay Queen's on again he'll keep them  well is now the moment to trade if you  didn't trade last time you might know  this time but okay Magnus Carlson  wow oh wait this is flashy because now  he's actually given up his Queen Magnus  now the black group here again he loves  to do this the black couldn't take the  White Queen because then the black Rook  would have dropped and Magnus I think is  trying to force a draw in a really  flashy way he's giving check to the  white king there's nowhere the white  king can hide without getting checked  and we'll see the position repeats  itself Magnus finding a really artistic  way to draw the game and there we go a  repetition of the position White's King  unable to stop the checks and it's a  draw all right